[Musique]
bonsoir merci à toute l'équipe de
bénévoles de tedx bonjour à l'école de
management de normandie qui nous voient
en live et encore un grand merci à tous
les organisateurs parce qu'ils font un
travail énorme
comme vous l'a dit harry je m'appelle
nicolas lemonnier je suis ostéopathe et
je suis avant tout papa papa d'un petit
charles et ce petit charles a changé ma
vie
là vous avez vous dire je me suis cours
je vous parle de charles de mon fils
c'est pourquoi il a changé ma vie parce
que le 30 juin 2015
j'ai appris avec ma femme qu'on allait
voir un peu ce petit garçon et ce jour
là j'ai eu un coup de massue d'émotion
de joie de peur de crainte de stress
plein plein plein de choses me sont
passées à travers la tête et là j'ai
compris mes parents avec toutes ces
émotions là que j'ai pu partager dans
durant toute mon enfance mon adolescence
et durant mes études
ce jour là j'ai pris conscience de ma
vie je faisais 95 kg je veux fumer un
paquet de cire grillades par jour je
travaillais de 8h à 21h tous les jours
et là je me suis dit non je veux pas
être comme ça je veux pas être ce papa
entre guillemets non modèle et je un peu
trahi sur moi pour devenir un papa entre
guillemets meilleur même si j'aime pas
ce mot là je me suis donc mis à courir
avec mon meilleur ami raphaël au fur et
à mesure des sorties
j'ai apprécié la course à pied en ayant
un goût du sang dans la bouche en
devenant rouge écarlate dès le deuxième
kilomètre et le lendemain de mes sorties
de running de marché comme un papy et
oui je faisais 15 j'ai fait quinze ans
de foot
et pourtant dix ans d'inactivité moi je
suis devenu comme ça et donc j'ai
commencé à courir enchaîné les sorties
les partager sur les réseaux sociaux
comme beaucoup de personnes le font sur
des groupes de runner et des milices
groupe de runner sur les réseaux sociaux
et un jour je pourrais pas vous dire
pourquoi le 5 décembre 2015 pour qui
pour quoi j'ai ramassé ce paquet de
cigarettes
je les postés sur les réseaux sociaux
vos lieux de ma tête de mettre la tête
en selle fille j'ai mis ce paquet de
cigarettes et jeudi maintenant je cours
et je ramasse des déchets hélas ce
jour-là plein de light plein de
commentaires pleins de pensées positives
oui bah moi je fais la même chose à
l'autre bout du monde oui moi j'ai envie
de le faire comment tu fais c'est très
simple tu cours j'aimerais sein des très
simple vu ce nombre de likes l'arbre
j'ai donc créé le groupe rené coty un
mois après au bout de quelques semaines
on était plusieurs centaines et ce qui
était étrange c'est que c'est plusieurs
centaines de personnes venaient de du
canada de norvège de nouvelle zélande du
japon en amérique du sud
et ça c'était assez impressionnant parce
qu'on n'était pas énorme mais en était
partout et ça c'était extraordinaire on
était déjà en quelques semaines dans 13
pays
donc ça s'était plutôt surprenant le 14
juillet 2016 donc sept mois après la
création de rené coty mme mark
zuckerberg par le biais d'une de ses
collaboratrices
marc m'a transmis un message et m'a dit
l'initiative on est content il nous
plaît peux tu nous en dire plus au début
je croyais que c'était une blague
j'étais en soirée avec des meilleurs
amis et shrek c'était une blague et au
finalement c'était pas une blague on a
échangé avec ces personnes là et au fil
des semaines ils m'ont proposé de faire
une vidéo
cette vidéo a dû mais dure 2 minutes 40
a été tourné à nantes dans ma ville et
j'ai eu la surprise trois semaines après
le tournage de cette vidéo qu'elle soit
posée par mark zuckerberg
inzell suis pas très anglophone le soir
de noël et le soir de noël j'étais chez
mes parents avec ma femme et mon fils et
32400 notification en trois minutes
téléphone intrigué je le déverrouille
j'étais pas au courant je déverrouiller
là je vois mark zuckerberg qualifié rené
coty mme de son histoire ce rythme là
c'est un raz de marée
heureusement que j'étais en vacances il
ya tous les médias quoi rappeler c'était
un peu ahuri sont le journal de 20
heures tf1 journée
de 20 heures de m6 400 médias dans le
monde et donc là l'association est passé
de 1200 à 13000 membres en espace de 24
heures la magie des médias les
journalistes me disent mais c'est
extraordinaire votre concept comment
vous avez fait pour inventer ça quand
vous avez fait pour charmer mark
zuckerberg
jardi bas j'ai couru j'ai ramassé un
déchet j'ai rien fait d'extraordinaire
mes grands parents qui étaient
agriculteurs je me rappelle encore quand
j'étais en vacances chez eux mais ils
balayent devant l'or devant chez eux
quoi y'a rien d'extra nord j'ai pas la
primeur d'avoir ramasser des déchets
pour la première fois de l'humanité
c'est juste du bon sens et après j'ai eu
la chance que mark zuckerberg de la voix
et ensuite le mettre en avant et donc à
l'issue de toute cette médiatisation là
on a créé des équipes d'événements des
équipes de partenariat des équipes
éducation et petit à petit on a créé
dans un petit peu partout dans le monde
parce que là actuellement on est dans
103 pays dans le monde et on a plus de
200 mille participants annuellement et
en créer 400 événements par tout ça avec
00 euros jusqu'à il ya neuf mois
facebook nous a soutenus il ya neuf mois
en nous donnant cinquante mille dollars
pour justement créer des projets ces
projets là c'est de faire courir le
maximum de monde et notamment les
enfants les enfants pourquoi parce que
c'est l'avenir de notre humanité
ils sont beaucoup plus ouverts à
l'écologie que certains adultes et en
fait ils ont encore ce regard innocent
quand on leur fait faire du sport et
qu'on leur fait ramasser un déchet y a
rien de plus beau
il ya deux jours j'ai posté un effet un
post sur un événement qu'on a créé avec
les tam-tams du coeur une association
dantesques et à proximité déjà eu vite
c'est une association qui donne du
matériel sportif aux enfants les plus
démunis et notamment cette année au
sénégal et ils m'ont envoyé une vidéo en
fait ils ont fait un rené coty mais avec
ces enfants là il était toujours temps
jouer de ramasser et nettoyer leur
village leur cour d'école les chemins de
leur rue et en tout en chantant ramasser
les papilles et vous jure sa meuf donné
les larmes aux yeux
et petit à petit les projets éducation
on les fait notamment la semaine
prochaine dans un lycée à nantes 300
étudiants aillent 300 collégiens avec
leurs correspondants qui viennent de
boston et en même temps on va leur faire
faire une activité sportive et en même
temps on va leur faire un cours avec un
support pédagogique
quel est l'intérêt de ramasser des
déchets de ne pas polluer la planète
quel est l'intérêt de diminuer son
système de consommation mais toujours
avec ce regard positif nos ambassadeurs
il y en a 84 dans 103 pays dans le monde
et il travaille toujours avec cette
humilité et avec cette transmission du
message positif
aaron un déchet tout simplement et après
si les participants de nous personne de
les participants de nos événements ont
une démarche chez soi après avoir couru
ramasser des déchets et se disent pour
être cohérent à 100% je vais diminuer ma
commande consommation de 2 2 capsules
nespresso
je vais faire le tri chez moi je vais
faire du jardinage au monde potager pour
motos suffit l'autonomie tout simplement
mais le pari est gagné on n'est pas là
pour donner des leçons des juste là pour
transmettre un message est que
transmettent que tout est possible on
est tous capable de changer le monde
on est tous capable de changer le monde
et vous même vous êtes capable de
ramasser un déchet et vous même vous
êtes capable de s'approprier un projet
qui va changer le monde et vous même
vous êtes capable de vivre votre votre
projet et il y a personne qui est
capable justement de vous mettre une
barrière et vous empêcher de faire ce
projet moi ce projet m'est tombé dessus
j'ai eu la chance que mark zuckerberg me
soutiennent après c'est une chance
incommensurable ça c'est sûr c'est
certain mais vous êtes tous capables de
faire et ça il faut le faire il faut
créer vos projets il faut aller au bout
des choses et on est tous capables de
transmettre ce message et transmettre
notre projet et c'est pour ça qu'on
travaille tous les jours toujours en
tant que bénévole c'est pas notre
activité moe chose de vos pâtes en
pleine campagne et on diffuse ce message
là avec ce positif ce côté positif
j'ai des exemples pierre-yves 1
un membre de rené qu à partir de la
semaine prochaine il va faire des
sorties rhône et côtes où les jeudis
soirs avec l'ensemble des salariés de
son entreprise
sébastien salariés d'un magasin de sport
à monaco qui est membre de rené co qui
organise des run & co a décidé depuis
deux semaines d'arrêt depuis deux mois
d'arrêter de vendre des bouteilles de
plastique parce qu'il s'est dit je vends
je fédéraux neko je ramasse des
bouteilles de plastique à longueur de
temps mais je vends des bouteilles de
plastique dans mon magasin
mais du coup j'arrête de vendre des
bouteilles de plastique et du coup cette
chaîne de magasins il ya 25 magasins qui
va arrêt qui vont arrêter de vendre des
bouteilles de plastique
vu que c'est une très grande chaîne de
magasins peut-être que demain il y en
aura 100 peut-être que dans deux
semaines aura mille et peut-être que
dans six mois il y en aura trois mille
uniquement son magasin à sébastien il ya
6000 bouteilles de plastique par an qui
sont vendus par imaginez si toute la
chaîne va juste va se diffuser comme ça
et rené causse et ça c'est vous venez
vous courrez vous ramasser des déchets
vous prenez conscience des choses avec
du plaisir parce que vous faites du
sport en même temps et après vous faites
votre projet à vous c'est un comme un
bassin d'éclosion et après vous faites
votre projet en tout cas un grand merci
et j'espère que les speakers et vous
vous allez prendre beaucoup de plaisir à
vivre vos projets et à changer le monde
ait oublié par une chose est sûre c'est
un run un déchet on est tous capable de
changer le monde
moi je le fais à ma manière vous pouvez
le faire à votre manière merci bonne
soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]